good morning believe nation today's
message is find your gift over to you
Cicely Tyson there was a time when I had
two or three jobs in the same day I'd go
here and do a little bit here and do a
little bit here and do a little bit and
people began to talk about you know this
new actress Cicely Tyson and next thing
I know I was here in front of you oh my
mother wasn't happy about what I was
doing she didn't like it she told me I
couldn't stay in her house and do back
whatever that was I was called by the
NIP cow and asked to come and read a
play called Dark of the Moon and it was
to be done at the Y in Harlem my mother
heard that I was going to do this play
she told my sister hmm she's going up
there and make a fool of herself okay so
I decided to invite her and she came and
she brought us a friend I made sure I
knew exactly where she was going to sit
so that I wouldn't look in that
direction
okay from the moment I walked out on the
stage
I heard her say oh my god ha ha she kept
talking to her friend all during the
time she thought she was whispering but
I could hear every word she said
it took me crazy at the end of this play
I come out and my mother is standing at
the door accepting congressional Tory
remarks from the people oh yes I always
knew ever since she was a little girl
that she was good you know she liked to
sing and dance and so I always knew she
was going to do this I said wait a
minute my mother who put me out of her
house and didn't speak to me for almost
three years is standing there telling
this barefaced story to these people ah
right so I knew that it was something
in within me that she felt was a gift so
I'd like to say that Michael Jordan is
not the greatest basketball player of
all time the greatest basketball player
of all time is a manager at Starbucks
because he never laced up because he
never realized that that was his real
gift and I think that so many people
walk to life that way I think so many
people have not discovered their gift
maybe not you guys as part of believe
nation but I think most of the world has
not discovered their gift and they know
they should be doing something else but
instead they're doing this thing because
it's safe because it's comfortable
because it's convenient because it pays
the bills it does because because
because all the practical reasons why we
do the things that we do instead of all
in our heart doing the thing that we
should be doing I think that's super
common I think we all have Michael
Jordan level talent as something and
most people have barely scratched the
surface of understanding what's possible
for them if you don't know what it is
you want to do means explore say yes the
things try things that's that idea that
you have just get started on it find
some small ways to build momentum and
get started what we tend to do is we
build this dream up in some big huge
thing the big vision that we want which
is amazing I love the thinking big but
then because it's so big we don't take
any action we tell ourselves that we
can't do that until we have funding or
can't do that until I meet this person
or get this connection or I move to that
country right we build up all of these
things that have to happen first before
we do anything to go to accomplish that
big goal and guess what happens nothing
you just sit on that idea for the rest
of your life and you die with your song
still left inside you instead of
releasing it to the world I love the big
thinking I love the big vision in the
Dreaming it's important it's motivating
that drives us it's inspiring but at the
same time you have to take action
immediately as soon as you set some big
huge goal for yourself that day you need
to start building some kind of a
made them do it if your big goal is to
write a book and have it be a
best-seller and get it published with a
major publisher that's what is you're
going to look inside you and it has to
come out and start start writing the
book start researching authors and how
they had success start going to industry
events and getting to know what the
process is all about start trying to
line up coffee meetings or interviews
with people who had some success along
the way look for meetup groups in your
local area the start building some kind
of momentum something take action you
want to be a youtuber great start do the
channel make your first video it's going
to suck that's okay do it again and do
it again and do it again whatever that
big dream of yours is you need to find a
way to get started immediately and build
some momentum and if you don't know it
then you explore until you find the
thing that makes you come alive and at
the beginning this is really important
at the beginning it's from here the
thing that you want to do is not going
to make any sense
practically you're going to come up with
all of these practical reasons why you
should not go out and do that and so
you're going to stay on this straight
path that you've been on before but how
happy are you and imagine 15 more years
of doing the same thing that you don't
like doing and it doesn't mean you just
throw everything away and go all the way
out here you don't have to burn the
boats necessarily I'm not that kind of
person but you have to do something you
have to take a little bit of time away
from this straight path to play out here
because if you don't you're never going
to do anything out here you know we're
going to get there daily consistent
action of some kind towards the
attainment of your dreams important
everybody has a dream everybody has some
big thing that they want to do and 99%
of people just complain what they can't
do it don't be that person you already
have the resourceful mess inside you to
move forward on your dreams and what are
you going to do about it
take action will complain it to it so
the question today today is I'm curious
what does that store you're telling
yourself as to why you're not going out
and accomplishing your bigger goal
what are you telling yourself with the
reason what's the expense what's the
complaint put it down and then laugh at
it and understand that you're better
than this and remember who you are leave
in the comments to be curious to find
out I also want to give a quick shout
out to Calvin Simpson Calvin thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
dear one word really means a lot to me
and I hope you are enjoying the read
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow morning for another shot event
spresso
[Music]
work on my gift I realized that all of
us are born with a gift but you got to
hone it you know it's just not you're
not going to become great and we talked
about the school of greatness you know
we talked about um you know greatness is
upon you and I realized that my gift
wasn't going to create itself my gift
wasn't going to nurture itself my gift
wasn't going to perfect itself that was
something I had to do and so then before
you know we did a video that went viral
I think it's got over 50 million hits
now and we turn our passion into a
profit it doesn't matter yeah I love it
your gift can be anything you can't look
at it that's simply running jumping
singing and dancing but I'll tell you
one thing your gift is the thing that
you do the absolute best with the least
amount of effort for me it was comedy so
once you identified then that's that's
the beginning of it but there's a lot of
work to do even after you identify your
gift you know you can believe you're
something all you want but if you don't
work towards it you just signa it's
gonna be empty well my message to you is
pretty much managers follow your dreams
another main I think a lot of people get
caught up and get sidetracked by what's
happening I'm around them it was cool
people always ignored a gift not
realizing that gift us was gonna take
you out of your poverty take you out of
your situation that gift of the trade is
an ultimate element that God provided
for you to get you out of any situation
or to take you to what's destined for
you you know some people are just great
at certain things but because music or
modeling or film is cool they a lien ate
what their gifts are just to be a part
of something that is pursued to be or
persuade to be cool I always felt like
you know my method and message always
has been disposed of the gifts that you
have put
emphasizing it concentrate on what you
feel that you're great in because what
you're great in is always gonna be what
pulls you out of the worst situation
that you could ever imagine it puts you
in a better situation large intestine